[Music]  your animatronics puppetry visible  effects  yeah looks fantastic this is a little  evolution of the crystal fox  [Music]  we'll do a combination of a hand puppet  they'll be animatronics in the face  and then we will make a perfect version  for CG I will then scan it to be able to  bring her to life in any way the Ryan  ones  [Music]  right you must have a thousand questions  where's ray something inside me is away  I need help  we're at Sparkle  that'll light the fire with burners  daughter down I was raised to fight  for the first time I had some things  fight for  rated pg-13  but the pastime the only way to become a  human today darkness rises  [Music]  night to meet  I need someone  to show me my place in all this  come on  this is not going to go away you think  you  you